oh okay this is heartbreaking i got so i
got an opinion on this one let's
go okay so cam newton over the weekend
was visiting
a football camp that he uh helped
created he funds
anyone to go out to support the kids
kind of be there as morale and there was
a
kid who was attending the camp talking
[ __ ] to cam newton
calling him a free agent and the
internet was basically reacting are you
a free agent can you
what yeah you're phrasing i'm rich yeah
and he's
super that's it he paid yeah
he was also mvp of the league yeah it's
the kid was just being a troll
he was just trying to go viral and then
cam like
all these other athletes got on their
defending cam the kid got lit up on the
internet like him trying to go viral
you went viral for the wrong for the
wrong [ __ ] social media wasn't like
yeah way to go kid they're like
can you imagine getting an opportunity
to chat to cam newton and you use it
never forget this before
and also what people don't realize is
all those kids at that camp that want to
be professional football players hate to
tell you odds are
none of you will even make it division
one college let alone win a heisman like
you did
let alone make the nfl be the number one
pick let alone not only make it to the
nfl
be the mvp of the nfl yeah he's one of
one man and he's a heisman trophy winner
did you yep
he said that oh he said that he said
that but a lot of people are uh giving
this kid a lot of flack because they're
saying that
he's yeah because cam gives back to the
community that he's from
he's constantly there trying to help
improve everyone's lives
where he came from and so this kid is at
his camp
benefiting off of him and trying to go
viral yeah it's so different and then
all athletes came out and leonard
fournette uh super ball winner for the
tempe buccaneers running back but
any young athlete watching this video
please don't be this kid don't miss your
chance to learn something from someone
who has been
there at the highest level in this sport
stay humble
he's so right man these [ __ ] idiot
kids
that's kids to date over what was your
take though my take was
okay so cam got up upset and this kid
this kid was like bro
i was just talking [ __ ] what happened to
the the
giving it back back and forth like
football is like talking [ __ ]
it's not though it's not he doesn't it's
never that they don't know each other
but but also
also this isn't another it's not like
teenagers teenager
dude when i was a kid i remember i did
uh the ed mccaffrey camp
i would no no no kid in their right mind
would talk [ __ ] to him
to the nvp what like what do you you're
in high school
yeah like i'm sorry were you what what
what stance are you
what's your stance what are you a
starter on your high school football
team
talking [ __ ] it's not like he was like
talking [ __ ] as another professional
athlete
that's whatever you can do that you're
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're in
high school yeah bro you ain't
[ __ ] get some accolades first you ain't
giving me [ __ ] not
i want to express my deepest apologies
cam newton my entire organization my
coaches for my actions
at the 7 7 tournament this past weekend
i did not intend for it to get as far as
it did first i would like to start off
by saying my parents
never taught me to people disrespectful
as a football player i let my
competitive competi what competitive
side
you know that's what you're saying no
this is like you know it's insane
it was a myth a moment and i realized
how a lot of you took it as disrespect
yeah yeah never mind humiliate and let
anyone down
i'm very appreciative for the community
yeah you talking about the where he
gives back
yeah i realize this can uh dictate my
future as young man having very big
goals dude you're never gonna make it uh
but i will not allow this to stop me
from getting where i need to be it will
so again i apologize and hope i can be
forgiven
they said i hope i hope don't matter
listen i hope the
chance to make it are still 0.0001 yeah
it's middle
let's nvp you're talking [ __ ]
to the nfl mvp yeah the first round
draft pick yeah
the guy who won a national championship
at auburn won the heisman which is you
know how many guys when heisman then go
on to win
mvp yeah are you out of your [ __ ]
mind
and cam newton demon wanna engage with
him yeah where's your dad at
let me talk to your dad yeah yeah yeah
exactly and you know and i hope like
yeah cause at the end of the day he he
is still a kid right so i hope like he
is able to like
does that does that affect his like
because again they said he was nice does
that affect his draft like coaches look
at him like oh he's a problem already
like going to like these colleges i
don't think so if he's good
he's not going to put up with it yeah
you know how many guys are nice though
a lot of people there's tons yeah but
i'm just saying that so my thing is he
even has
we don't know how good it is you know he
even has the wrong attitude going into
this
seven on seven years yeah yeah so if you
have an attitude going to seven on seven
community
that's your birthday yeah dude trust me
there's way nicer people out there
yeah that's what i'm saying i don't
think so if he's like undeniable they're
still i mean
i don't know i would still recruit him
hopefully he learns from it yeah just
what a [ __ ] hopefully
yeah super how many nfl players how many
nfl mvps how many heisman trophy winners
do you meet where you talk
[ __ ] but that's the internet and he
thought oh this is what we
do and then everyone's like it's not
what we do so
his only accolade is looking bad on
camera against a formula i think he
thought he'd go viral talking [ __ ] to
cam newton he thought
like because online people should on cam
he thought everyone's like yeah way to
go and they're like
oh oh this ain't the way to do it yeah
because you ain't [ __ ] you ain't [ __ ]
you're trying to get to where cam is
yeah yeah like for cam like you won't
even entertain it
that's nice that's like
people that are fans of football and
[ __ ] like yeah that's that kind of
[ __ ] energy
not someone that's like trying to
[ __ ] eventually become
yeah now if you don't want to be cam
newton yeah exactly if you even if you
have cam talent i don't think you even
like
belittle yourself to go at cam like that
if i was out there bawling i was like
like kevin yeah
yeah yeah but it's back now if another
mvp like criticized cam
then i'm sure cam would debate with you
but because he's been in his shoes you
debate with us like lamar jackson lamar
jackson goes up to him like bro you
ain't no you respect him because lamar
jackson well he's he's made it he's
there
yeah this kid is trying to get the
height to [ __ ] college vision one
college yeah at a seven o'clock oh he's
he's 19 is that what they said he was
he's a high schooler high school at 19.
well he's 19. i think he's 19. he's a
kid yeah he's a kid bro
i bet he's just getting belittled
probably a wake-up call for him too yeah
yeah probably good for him
hopefully they don't go too hard on it i
know
just people in general like in the past
but his homies probably you know
[ __ ] all that well this is video right
here i think so this one right
yeah two minutes long nah i saw that
a lot of people do the uh smaller clips
but this is
a different angle longer
we go to the
want some attention i'm gonna beginning
you some attention the right way bro
the right way when do y'all play
what was your record today
what did you do
someone said he's talking [ __ ] as crocs
please
but you never said what you did you said
you won't see me
if i was his [ __ ] coach and his coach
trying to talk to him
this coach talking to him right now it's
a grown man
coach
uh
all right
[Music]
that's one of them kids in the hood
where it's like man whatever i ain't
trying to hit none of that
so yeah and you're gonna stay in the
hood with that attitude yeah
damn you gotta yeah you gotta get out
your own way oh boy was but again you
can't turn it off like
i'm trying to talk to you he's like man
you're gonna see yeah i know it's like
bro i'm trying to talk to you
listen camera strategy how are you going
to impress man man perspective this guy
is a little boy and
he's still in his mindset so he's like
man i don't know he's spitting
i've been there before you spitting in
front of someone you nervous yeah he's
sitting there spitting i'm like
yeah cause every the attention is on you
he didn't want that smoke
you know like he's like grown man
conversation imagine being an open mic
or saying some [ __ ] to bill bird
and then he calls you out from there all
the comments from all the comments yeah
you got [ __ ] to [ __ ] say
and he's but this even like being like
uh open micro talking bill bird this
would be like being a
a person who bought a ticket to bill
bird's free show
and then talking [ __ ] yeah yeah that's
why you're special in [ __ ] and you're
like
do you have a special yeah but yours was
[ __ ] that's fine
but do you have a special yeah no i'm
i you know i want to be okay what we're
not in the same lane dude
that's why you can't put any energy
unless someone's
in your shoes or in the same path you
put zero energy into it
zero yeah i couldn't imagine talking
[ __ ] to a cheerleader way better than me
what's yeah exactly what's that snow at
least you're a cheerleader at least at
least i'm a cheerleader this kid's not
right like you know what i'm saying like
it's just insane yeah
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son